son los ojos de la otan en el cielo
aviones como estos utilizan el sistema
de alerta y control aéreo conocido como
aguax este avión en particular se dirige
a Ucrania para pasar 10 horas vigilando
la actividad inusual a bordo hay 30
militares de todo el mundo las alertas
son habituales
acabamos de detectar un dispositivo de
diseño ruso no tenemos más información
de nuestros sensores está despegando de
belarus y se dirige a Rusia podemos
suponer que se tratan potencialmente de
tropas rusas destacadas en belarús que
regresan a casa
otros operadores de vigilancia estudian
la velocidad la altitud y concretamente
las intenciones de los aviones que están
vigilando
se está comunicando por lo que podría
ser de combate u otro tipo de avión y no
sigue por lo tanto el procedimientos
normales
toda la información recogida a bordo es
altamente clasificada los datos se
cifran y se transmiten en tiempo real a
todos los miembros de la otan la
duración y el número de emisiones de
estos aviones se ha duplicado debido a
la duración de los vuelos tienen que
repostar en el aire un proceso delicado
para repostar tienes que poner aviones
pesados uno junto al otro a unos 20 pies
y tienes que mantener la posición de
forma precisa
según Rusia la información obtenida se
transmite a los ucranianos si se utiliza
en su esfuerzo bélico
desde el punto de vista militar no
proporcionamos información a los
ucranianos la otan sigue manteniendo que
no es parte del conflicto pero no
descarta que algunos de sus 30 miembros
compartan los datos con las autoridades
ucranianas